à travers la Russie des milliers de
réservistes convoqués pour rejoindre des
centres d'entraînement de l'armée avant
d'aller combattre sur le front ukrainien
degré ou de force
ne pas se présenter et passible de 10
ans de prison alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter comment vous avez
été réformé parce que c'est votre
première finalement votre première scène
j'adore j'étais réformé P5 quoi débile
profond
pas léger profond sur ces images
beaucoup protestent invoque des
problèmes de santé ou expliquent qu'ils
ont des enfants à charge mais les
militaires comme sur cette vidéo
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux se
montrent très ferme
mais pourquoi vous criez comme des
femmes
fermez-la et tenez vous
je suis caché
il est où il est où Camille c'est
incroyable
du décor incroyable c'était Florent
depuis le début je l'avais pas vu dans
cette ville de la région séparatiste de
Donetsk les votes se poursuivent
beaucoup se prononcent en faveur de
l'annexion de certains territoires par
la Russie des référendums jugés
illégitimes par le président ukrainien
le monde réagira avec la plus grande
justesse au pseudo référendum ils seront
condamnés sans équivoque les autorités
de Donetsk assurent que des mesures ont
été prises pour éviter la fraude
chacune a été scellé elle est scellée et
fermée de façon hermétique dans tous les
cas quand on l'a prise elle était vide
et ensuite quand on l'a rapportera au
bureau de vote nous comparerons le
nombre de signatures et le nombre de
bulletins
vous voulez un vieux la visibilité des
frontières alors restaurer l'Union
soviétique qu'est-ce qu'il propose
ils disent nous ne la reconnaîtrons
jamais
comme l'a écrit l'écrivain Gogol je vous
ai donné la vie et je vous la reprendrai
c'est comme ça
si j'étais président de la République
pour parler comme les comme à l'hôpital
psychiatrique je rappellerai mon
collègue la Scholtz j'irai voir le
président chinois et je pense qu'il est
la seule personne au monde aujourd'hui à
pouvoir dire à Poutine il faut arrêter
les conneries voilà pour la théorie mais
à l'étage au-dessus cette femme n'est
pas inscrite
à Maxime ovna
sa petite fille oui elle n'est pas là
devant notre caméra elle va voter à sa
place
signé juste là
[Musique]
et on va traverser cette tempête on
reste tous ensemble tous unis
je souhaite l'amour physique de ma
famille vous savez il y a quelque chose
de génial dans le fait de souhaiter la
mort des gens c'est pas pour ça que ça
arrive dans le métro il m'est déjà
arrivé de souhaiter la mort de quelqu'un
parce que parce qu'il mangeait et si on
m'avait annoncé son décès j'aurais été
quelqu'un de votre famille qui vous
entend dire je souhaite la mort totale
de ma famille peut avoir une crise
cardiaque le jeune cavalier ce sont
euphorique c'est l'effet du calmant
qu'il a reçu
[Musique]
j'ai rêvé d'une baleine et d'un orque il
y a deux jours
voilà je sais pas si
il faut du rythme
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les soirs et ça fait un bazar aussi
80 ans
si je regarde les cibles à chaque fois
c'est pour les plus de 80 ans après
voilà ils sont très gentils voilà après
moi c'est pas mon délire j'ai fait une
fois frère il y avait que des des
personnes voilà qui étaient décédés qui
me marientaient dans la rue je voudrais
beaucoup de choses après c'est tabou
voilà moi je suis pas je suis pas non
plus fan des séries qu'ils ont tendance
à se moquer je vous souhaite bien
entendu de vous faire du bien mais plus
encore de nourrir la joie et pas la peur
ne pas former ce gros nuage n'oubliez
pas que la conscience crée la matière
c'est nous qui créons la réalité alors
restez joyeux et faites-vous du bien
merci à tous vraiment merci